[Music]
before marble wraps up a decade of
storytelling an endgame go back to where
their movies began
nope before that even earlier the
president thanks getting warmer hmm my
little airbrushed beauty yep there it is
Howard the Duck experienced the first
feature-length film based on a Marvel
comic that in a weird way set the stage
for things to come featuring their first
sky being first forgettable alien
villain and first alcoholic womanizing
hero really the only reason it failed is
because they got everything else wrong
so very very wrong
how would you really are the worst suit
up with Howard just don't look too hard
at the suit because it's extremely jakey
how about when they can wrap up that
machine and send me back home when he's
plucked from duck world and sent a
Cleveland's glam rock district he'll
embark on an epic quest to complain
about whatever's in front of him talk
about a rotten day oh now I'm really
depressed while outside forces literally
drag him through the whole movie against
his will
[Music]
it's okay Howard we don't want to be
here either but this duck won't fly
alone prepare for an ensemble film where
every character can be described as the
dumb one featuring Tim Robbins as the
entire cast of Big Bang Theory at once
and Beverly the girl is down to
experiment no matter how wrong it feels
you think I'm my friend happiness in the
animal kingdom tacky because aside from
the fact that she's trading food and
shelter for sex
hi headache and I got the ASP Ducks have
corkscrew-shaped penises that extend the
links of their entire bodies this
relationship and defies all the laws of
nature and physics but this isn't a
serious film meant to be analyzed it's a
goofy comedy and on that level it's also
terrible because whatever problems you
may have with the MCU scripts it's
nothing compared to the relentless
barrage of duck puns seeing I doc what's
is the key to your duck Rovio and Frank
dr. house
no one laps and a master of quack fool
so many ducking puns man these are
fouled crap now they've got me doing it
mother
so settle in for what should have been a
superpower team-up between Marvel Comics
and George Lucas yep that George Lucas
that was such a disaster it snapped
Marvel movies out of existence for a
decade and forced George to sell the
animation division of Lucasfilm that
would go on to become Pixar so hey even
if this duck sucked at least it gave us
a woody I'm sorry this this is what
happens when you watch Howard the Duck
more than once guys thanks but once was
plenty starring snark wing Duck Madonna
Neal the mast I see Ferris Bueller ducks
off duck rubber you're the one and
whoever wrote the screenplay I've been
doing too much toot
[Music]
Doug fails Chuck it's your cousin Marvin
Barry
you know the new sound you looking for
this family isn't it to fit even more
Game of Thrones into your eyeballs click
the box to watch our after-show watching
Thrones or if you need to get caught up
before the game concludes check out our
Kremen of the complete series I really
wanted those elephant's these are the
plums I've been on about all week I
ain't no hollaback girl